MARK BALL: Hi.
My name is Mark Ball.
I am here with
you all at Google.
I'm on a team, actually,
called team and organization
development.
And we get to work
with team development
all across the company,
so it's super fun.
And I first took a course
called "Art of Living" course
over 20 years ago
and was blown away
by the effectiveness of
using the breath to-- hello,
John-- using the breath to get
into deep states of meditation
very easily and quickly.
And then-- so, for 10 years,
just doing the techniques
and getting more and more amazed
at how effective they were,
I finally decided,
OK, go to the source.
Go to India.
And then, went there, and I was
definitely not disappointed.
To me, it was such a completely
non-conceptual, very concrete
like here's the things
that these practices,
and techniques, and
ways of thinking do.
Not just the stress
reduction, which
is obviously very nice, and
especially now as a new father,
I really appreciate
the techniques
that can reduce stress.
But even other kind of crazy
things-- thank you [INAUDIBLE].
Other experiences,
too, that I wouldn't
have thought-- much more kind
of subtle and just interesting
and fun to have.
Those kinds of experiences
were there, too.
Greeting me there was Kashi.
And I haven't told
you this before,
but many very nice people
there at the center-- this
is the Art of Living
center in India.
So there's hundreds of people
there running the place.
Everybody's very nice.
But you alone were
really genuine
and genuinely interested in
who I was and what I was doing.
And it was such a warm welcome.
Coming from a different country
to stay for a few months,
it was a big deal for me.
Kashi was there after
having graduated
from IIT Mumbai, which I looked
up on "Wall Street Journal"
this morning, said it's arguably
harder to get into the IITs,
any of the IITs, than it
is to MIT or to Harvard.
So very impressive
school system.
So not only a deep,
deep knowledge
of what you're
going to hear about,
but also this tremendous brain.
So I thought that
was very Googly.
I think that's pretty much all
I wanted to say in introduction.
Well, more things about him.
He's been teaching a lot.
So he's taught-- not just like
a number that I'm making up,
but a literal
number, if you were
to count the people--
over 500,000 people
in various techniques through
the "Art of Living" programs.
If you're interested--
and I don't
know if he's going to--
if he talks about any
of the techniques during
this talk, some of them
are offered in a program
that we have here
called Sky Meditation.
So you don't even
have to go off campus,
if you're in Mountain View,
to get involved with that.
And what might be the
go link if you wanted
to know about Sky Meditation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK BALL: Oh, OK,
go/SkyMeditation.
Kashi.
DINESH KASHIKAR: Thank you.
Thank you, Mark.
So the topic of what
I'm going to speak today
is about pouring water on your
table and still able to smile.
There a lot of things
that the universe
throws at us which
transforms the way
we think about the world, which
affects the way we function.
But each of us has an innate
ability, or innate capability,
of doing the reverse, of
having an impact on the world
rather than the universe
having an impact on us.
Through the ancient
times, people
thought about this,
medicated on this.
And all that knowledge,
all that experience,
is available to us today as the
Veda, or the Vedic tradition.
As I went through college, I
experienced modern technology,
but I had the good fortune
of having been brought up
in a family where the Vedic
traditions were followed, too.
While I was in school, I didn't
really appreciate it so much.
I knew there was something
to my background.
But as I started looking
at technology more,
as I start learning
about science more,
I realized there are many
things that are common.
And like Mark said,
after doing all
that, when I started
exploring inner technology,
or the signs of the
spirits, so to speak,
started learning about myself.
I realized there's so many
things that we can really use.
And that's what brought
me on this journey.
So the talk today
is about my journey
through this whole--
the Vedic experience--
and how it was so relevant for
me, very practical for me, what
learnings we can take
from this, and how
it can be useful for
each one of us out here.
Throughout this session, please
feel free to interrupt me.
Ask questions at any time.
I'm OK with that.
At any point of time if
my accent is too Indian
and you don't
understand something,
please feel free to smile.
I'll understand.
So the word Veda itself
comes from the Sanskrit
root [INAUDIBLE],
which means "to know."
We know our environment
through various means.
Through the five
senses-- seeing,
hearing, touching,
feeling, tasting.
There's so much input that
happens to this nervous system.
All of the methods of knowing
all the ways in which we
are knowing gets put together.
All the knowledge
that we accumulate
comes together as the Veda.
As more and more scientists
add to this body of knowledge,
it grows vaster and vaster.
Initially, when they
started printing books,
books were a very
rare commodity.
And then they started
getting stored in places.
Very soon, there
were so many books
that there was a need
to categorize them.
And the library system
came into existence.
I don't know if people
still remember--
there's the Dewey Decimal
system of numbering books based
on the topic.
So as the subjects
got vaster, they
started cataloguing
them and arranging them.
That's what happened
in ancient India, too.
And they called it "The Vedas."
They said, based on the kind of
knowledge, let's categorize it.
So the first thing
they did was they
said, OK, there are four Vedas.
Let's categorize
all this knowledge
and put it into four buckets.
So the first bucket was
called the the "Rigveda."
The Rigveda is all about
the principles, or the,
for want of a better
word, principles.
Then comes the Yajurveda,
which means the application
of those principles.
Then comes the
Samaveda, which has
to do with the rhythm,
or the harmony,
or the beauty, the music.
And then comes the
Atharvaveda, which
is about our mundane existence,
about our day to day lives.
So if you look at
knowledge, there
are different
types of-- e equals
mc squared was an equation.
There are so many equations
that we learn in college
but hardly ever use later on.
Maybe we all had to go through
differentiation and integration
calculus.
And after the exam was
over, very few people
actually use it.
Maybe you actually use it here.
I have no idea.
But if you look at it, there
are a lot of principles,
and then there are application
of those principles.
Some people are more interested
in ideation, in ideas.
And some people are more
interested in application
of those ideas.
So those who are
more ideation, more
getting to the basic principles,
I would say they are Rigvedis.
Their brain makeup is more
of the kind of Rigveda.
And if you put them to
do something practical,
it doesn't work.
There are some people who
love to make things practical.
Bring it down to existence.
For example, if
you take a string,
stretch it and
pluck it, it's going
to vibrate at a
certain frequency.
If you change the length
of the string, the tension
of the string, the
material of the string,
it's going to change the
frequency at which it vibrates.
That's Rigveda, the principle.
Someone said, OK,
this is the principle.
Let's put six strings
on a piece of wood,
put some frets and we
make it into a guitar.
It's the same principle,
but it's now come down
into the form of a guitar.
That's Yajurveda.
A person who does the
research on the stress
and tension in the string has
nothing to do with the guitar.
And a person who
makes the guitar,
he just needs to
know the equations.
He's not worried
about how it works.
If I have a phone,
most probably I
would look at the
features inside it.
A person who's
designing the phone
would probably look at all the
processes that go behind it.
You give me a guitar, I
can probably make sound.
But if I have to create music,
I need to know how to play it.
So even if you have
something very practical,
unless we know how
to create music,
that's another level of knowing.
I can appreciate good
music, but to create
that music needs another skill.
And that skill is the
Samaveda, how to create music.
How to create harmony.
When I say music, it
doesn't mean just music,
but how to use that practical
knowledge and create harmony,
make it beautiful.
Different types of music
affect us in different ways.
If someone plays some
tune, you probably
want to stand up and dance.
Some other music makes
you feel, OK, I just
want to close my eyes and relax.
Impact of that knowledge
on the human psyche,
that's a different
ball game altogether.
There are people who
make great music,
and there are people who
can analyze that music.
So in this example,
if you look at it,
the equations of the stretched
string, that's Rigveda.
Creating the guitar
was the Yajurveda.
The Samaveda is how to
make music out of it.
And what impact
does that music have
on people, groups of people,
that's the [INAUDIBLE].
Each of us usually has one or
a couple of these capabilities.
Some of us are great at ideas,
not good at implementing.
Some of us are great
managers, but not very
good at creating harmony.
Some people can get
groups of people together,
make it all work.
But if you have to do something
practical, it doesn't work.
And some people are at the
front and can look at the impact
that this is going
to have on people
and make decisions
according to that.
So if we look at all these
four aspects of knowing,
it translates to how
we live our life.
Sometimes, we have one
of these Vedas in excess.
Others, we don't have.
And we wonder, why
am I not progressing?
What is it that I
need to focus on?
So if you look at these four
Vedas, then it gives us a clue.
Where can I put some attention?
Where do I need to move ahead?
Maybe you're great at
harmonizing with people,
but ideation might
not be so good.
So there are two
things we can do.
They said if you have
to learn these Vedas,
if you have to become
proficient in the Vedas,
they said there
are six Vedangas.
There are six
aspects to this Veda.
The six limbs of the Veda.
Anga means "limb."
For example, if I have
a body, but the hands
enable me to do
something with them.
I might have a great
idea, but to type it out,
I need my fingers.
I use my legs to take my body
from one place to another.
So in that sense, the limbs help
the body to function properly.
And this is what
the Vedangas do.
The Angas starts with Shiksha.
Shiksha means how
to create the sound.
When I say something when
I'm speaking something,
I'm creating sound.
And if I need to
communicate properly,
if I need to
understand properly,
first I need to go into the
root of-- so creating the sound.
Then comes Nirukta,
or how to put
sounds together to create words.
Then comes Vyakarana, or
how do I put words together
to create sentences.
Then comes Chandas, what is
the rhythm in the sentence.
The same sentence, when
I speak in a certain way,
creates a certain impact.
Spoken in another way, it
creates another impact.
The intonation.
Hello.
It's just one word,
but the way we speak
it conveys much more sense.
So how do I convey sense
using-- Then comes Jyotisha.
Jyotisha is the impact of time.
Getting the timing right is
the key to communication,
the key to knowledge.
How do I-- if I can
get my timing right,
then I get the results.
And the sixth one is
Kalpa, or the context.
When we take care of all
these six aspects of the Veda,
of knowing, then we are
able to polish our knowing,
so to speak.
Some of these seem
to be quite obvious--
how to make the sound.
But there is a big
science behind it.
You know, a lot of times, fights
begin with "but I told you."
I thought I said something.
Someone else thought they
heard something else.
And that's where the
misunderstanding starts.
So this communication
is the key to knowledge.
And when we can look
at all these aspects,
that increases all these
four aspects of knowing,
which is the Rigveda, Yajurveda,
Samaveda, Atharvaveda.
OK.
There are all these things.
But all of this seems to
be very impractical to me.
How do I do it?
What is it that I can do?
So then they said
there are six version,
six ways of seeing this, six
ways of experiencing this.
So the first darshana is Nyaya.
Now, [INAUDIBLE]
realized that there
are different types of people.
You can't say the same
thing to everyone.
When I came into this-- when
all of us came into this hall,
and I started speaking,
everyone was looking intently.
Maybe some of the people
up there on the live stream
were watching.
And then, after some
time, some of us
were very interested-- oh,
yeah, I want to know more.
Some of us were
waiting, OK, let's
come to the practical aspects.
Then we'll start listening.
So each of us has a
different mindset.
So [INAUDIBLE] said,
the Vedic scholar
said, let's address all
these mindsets separately.
So the first one is
called Nyaya, or logic.
There are some people
who are logical,
who need a reason
for everything.
Someone comes and says, oh,
this meditation is excellent.
And the question
is, OK, who says so?
Where is the research?
Where are the testimonials?
I want proof.
So some of our minds work
proof and logic, Nyaya.
There is conversely
another attitude
which says it doesn't matter
what everyone is saying,
I want to know for myself.
Unless I experience it,
it's going to be no use.
That is Vaisheshika, vaishesha.
"Vaishesha" means
"special" or "knowing."
So the first darshana
is Nyaya, or logic.
And the second is Vaisheshika,
or personal experience.
Now if you look at
people around you,
there are some people
who need logic,
some people who need
to have testimonials,
who need to have proof.
And there are some people
who base their life
on experience-- I want to know.
If you talk to a Nyaya person
in a Vaisheshika manner,
a person who likes
logic and you tell them,
no, no, you sit
here and experience.
He says, no, I'm not interested.
And if a person is interested
in Vaisheshika, in experience,
and you throw numbers and facts
and figures at them, they say,
all this doesn't impress me.
Show me the result.
Nyaya and Vaisheshika.
Then comes Yoga and Samkhya.
Samhkya-- "Samhkya"
means counting.
And Yoga means uniting.
When we count, we are analyzing.
OK, there are two
categories of people
in this room-- male and female.
There are people with long
hair, short hair, no hair.
So we can categorize.
Some people like to
see the differences--
how is this different from me?
And some people like
to see the union-- what
is there that's common?
And the last one is
Mimamsa and Vedanta.
Some people love rituals.
When you get to your
office, you want your things
in a certain manner.
If you look at people's desktop,
you probably can make an idea.
Some people have all kinds of
things put in folders somewhere
deep down.
And some people have all
their files on the desktop.
You know, when I was in college,
I used to stay in a hostel.
And my friend who used to
stay in the next room, one
day his mother visited.
She came to his room, and she
saw that it was very creativity
organized.
So she thought she
would do him a good turn
and she arranged everything,
put everything in place,
folded all the clothes,
put them nicely.
When he came back, he told-- he
said, Mom, you've spoiled it.
It's all chaotic now.
I can't find what is where.
Some people find order in chaos.
Some people find that without
order, there is chaos.
So when we recognize
these different ways
of looking at
knowledge, then we're
able to appreciate the other
person's point of view.
And to do all this,
first what is required
is that the mind
needs to be settled.
And the mind is
so agitated, then
it's very difficult to
perceive all these aspects,
to appreciate these
other aspects.
And that's where the techniques
of yoga, the part of yoga,
evolved as a method
of implementing,
of acquiring this knowledge.
If you notice, the whole of our
life, the quality of our life,
depends in a certain way
on the state of the mind.
We all might be in the same
situation, yet each of us
reacts to it differently.
Because each of us
are individuals.
So if we can do something
about the state of the mind,
then it makes a
great difference.
For example, you are here
sitting in front of me
and hearing, seeing.
Hopefully.
And you're listening
to me speaking.
But if you actually look at it,
the experience of those words
is happening inside the mind.
I might touch this podium.
The podium is there, but
what I'm experiencing
is actually inside.
The touch happens inside.
So if you look at
it, all perception
is actually happening inside.
Even though, whether the objects
are there outside or not,
but the experience
of the objects
is happening in the mind.
And therefore, when
we can have an impact
on the state of the mind, it can
change the experience, how we
experience the world outside.
The techniques of yoga
help us to go into that.
And that's why, even
though we might not
be able to change
what is there outside,
we can definitely change
the experience of that
which is outside.
And by changing
that experience, we
change the way we
interact with the world.
Have you noticed,
sometimes what people
say seems to have a great
impact on the state of our mind.
Someone says something,
we get upset,
and then it takes a long time
for us to come out of it.
But with these techniques,
we're able to reduce that impact
and increase these efficiency.
When I was in
college, I always felt
that I needed about
28 hours every day.
I was playing soccer
for my college, theater.
I did hundreds of things.
And one day, one of my friends
said, come do these things.
And I said, OK, let's see.
We'll find out how it works.
I gave my experience.
And then, when I
started meditating,
suddenly I realized
it was so effective
that I got more time every day.
My sleep reduced without having
any impact on my efficiency.
And that's how I started
knowing more, studying more.
And then I started sharing.
Have you had this experience?
Sometimes you're
sleeping at night.
And in the morning, it seemed
as if the body has woken up,
but the mind has
not yet woken up.
The body starts fidgeting,
but you say, OK,
let me sleep for a
little more time.
Someone did a research.
They said, oh, let's
find out how much time
is ideal to sleep.
They asked a lot of people.
And finally, they figured out
that the ideal amount of time
to sleep is five more minutes.
It doesn't matter
how much you sleep.
You press the snooze button
and say, just five minutes.
Those five minutes seem
to be really precious.
So if you'll notice the kind of
lifestyle that we're leading,
maybe 50 years back, most of
our work was physical in nature.
But today, most of our work
seems to be mental in nature.
The amount of input
that comes to our mind
has increased with
the internet, phones.
There used to be a time when
you would walk out of house,
and you were not contactable.
You were free.
But today, wherever you
go, something follows you.
What better place to
say this then here?
Somehow, information--
the amount
of information that's there
today, that's available
and that goes into
our nervous system--
has increased tremendously.
But at the same time, the
amount of physical activity
that happens in the body,
that seems to have reduced.
And this imbalance
creates an imbalance
in our resting patterns in
a certain way, I would say.
And that's where the
techniques of meditation,
which enable us to rest deeply,
can make such a big impact
on our system, that can help
bring back this balance.
And that really is
Veda-- the knowing.
That enhances our knowing.
Have you noticed that
our-- the way we know,
the way we interact
with our environment,
the efficiency seems
to keep changing.
At some point-- some
people are morning people.
Get up in the morning fresh,
and by the end of the day,
you just want to-- but there
are, conversely, other people
who are not morning people.
Very difficult to get up in
the morning, but late at night,
you tell me how much
to work, I can work.
But during the
day, mornings not.
So each one of us has different
cycles, different rhythms.
And if you can work
with these rhythms,
then that can enhance
our knowing, our Veda.
Enhance all these
aspects of the Veda.
Whether it's the
principles, the Rigveda.
There's the application,
the Yajurveda.
Whether it's the harmony,
or the music, or the rhythm.
This is the Samaveda.
Or whether it's the mundane
aspect of knowledge,
knowing what to do, how
to interact with people.
All these aspects build up as
we do all the meditation, all
these practices.
That's why I would say, if
these practices might not
have been relevant, so
relevant 50 years ago.
But with the increase
in our information,
it becomes all the more
relevant in today's age.
So I would like to present
before everyone-- if it's OK,
we'll do a short meditation
and a breathing technique which
you can take home with
you, take back with you
from this session, that
you can practice regularly.
You know, anything,
any technique,
when you practice a little bit
more, it increases [INAUDIBLE].
You're able to do it better.
For example, we
learned how to ride
a bicycle when we were small.
But the first time we
sat on the bicycle,
it probably felt
as if, not for me.
But doing it a couple
of times, slowly it
became so natural that today we
can ride one, if we ride one,
without even thinking about it.
So the rest of this
session, I'm going
to talk a little bit about
techniques-- some things
that we can do to
improve or enhance
the state of how we feel so that
all these aspects of knowledge
can blossom.
So let's start with just shaking
the hands wherever we are.
If you're sitting too
close to each other,
and you can shift
a little bit, make
sure you have space around you.
And relax.
Let's roll our shoulders.
And in the opposite direction.
And relax.
If you have space
around you, you
can take your arms to the sides.
And pull the fingers
towards yourself.
Spread the fingers a
little wider apart.
Don't forget to breath.
Keep pulling the fingers
towards yourself.
Push away with the
palm, as if you're
trying to push the walls.
If you look at me so seriously,
I feel really afraid.
And release.
Bring the hands down.
Interlock the hands together,
the fingers together,
and place them behind the head.
Gently press the head
forward with the hands.
Push the head forward
with the hands.
With your head,
push the hands back.
Nothing is moving.
You're just feeling
the pressure.
And as you breathe in, push
the elbows back a little bit.
Stay there and keep breathing.
And gently release the hands.
Bring them down.
With the right hand,
press the right side
of the head-- with your
right hand, or some hand.
And gently press the head.
With your neck, you're
resisting that pressure.
It's OK to smile.
And gently release the hand.
Other side.
A gentle pressure.
Feeling the sensation on
the neck, in the upper back.
And gently release the hands.
Once again, let's
roll our shoulders.
Notice the difference.
And in the opposite direction.
And relax.
Gently bring the ears
towards the shoulders.
If you feel some discomfort,
do not go too much.
Just do as much as you can.
Keeping the neck straight,
look left and right.
If you want to lose weight,
this is the perfect pose to do.
Just do this when there's
food in front of you.
And relax.
Interlock the hands
in front of the chest.
And this time,
twist a little bit.
Breathing out,
twist to the side.
Breathe in to center.
Breathe out, twist to the side.
Breathe out to the side,
breathe in to center.
Breathe out to the
side, breathe in center
and come back to center, relax.
Place the hands on the
knees in front of you.
As you breathe in, look up.
Push the chest forward.
And as we exhale, let's
bring the chin to the chest,
arch the back behind us.
Breathing in, look up.
Push the chest forward.
Exhale, arch the back.
Bring the chin to the chest.
Once again.
Breathe in, look up.
Exhale, arch the back,
bring the chin to the chest.
And relax.
Gently, as we breathe out,
let the shoulders move
to the right.
Breathe in to center.
Breathe out, bend a
little bit to the left.
Breathe in to center.
Breathe out to the right.
Breathe in, center.
Breathe out, left.
And relax.
The three major movements for
our spine-- front and back,
twisting, and sideways.
If you can just do
these few things,
it helps to keep the spine
held in a certain way.
A lot of times,
sitting in one posture,
we do not do these movements.
So just a few of
these movements can
help to relax a lot of the
muscle systems of the spine.
And once the body is relaxed,
then it's easier to meditate.
Otherwise what happens
when we start to meditate,
then suddenly we
realize we have a body.
If you're sitting for watching
a movie, three hours, two hours,
you can sit perfectly still.
But when you sit for
meditation, in five minutes,
you say, oh, I have back pain.
Which is why doing some gentle
movements like this, very
useful before a meditation.
Then we'll go on to a
breathing technique.
Now this is called,
variously, nadi [? sodhana ?]
and [? anuloma viloma, ?] or
alternate nostril breathing.
Many ways in which to do it.
But what this-- the way
we'll be doing it here
today, our whole purpose is to
breathe in from one nostril,
breathe out from the other.
Breathe in from one nostril,
Don't worry.
We'll have some help.
If you think only
superhumans can do that,
I don't think I can-- like.
So we're going to
use our fingers.
Place our hands
in this position.
It's like the thumb on the
right nostril, index finger
and middle finger in between
the eyebrows, and ring finger
and little finger, you can
bend them and place them
on the left nostril.
So this is the position
for the fingers.
Now, the middle two
fingers-- the index finger
and the middle finger--
gently touching
in between the eyebrows.
So | want, in this technique,
all the five fingers
to touch the skin.
And we'll move as
little as possible.
So what we're going to do is
either increase the pressure
from the thumb or increase the
pressure with the ring finger.
Without moving the
hands, it's just
going to change the pressure
and control the breath flow,
moving it either right or left.
So let's keep our
hands in this position.
With the eyes closed, breathe
in from both nostrils.
Press the thumb, exhale left.
Breathe in left,
and exhale right.
Breathe in right,
and exhale left.
Breathe in left.
Continue at your own pace.
Gentle breaths, moving the
hands as little as possible.
Four more breaths
in this fashion.
Put all your attention
on the breath.
And after breathing
out from the left side,
we may relax the hands,
keep the eyes closed.
Keeping the eyes closed,
let's bring our hands
onto the laps, palms
facing upwards.
Gently, let's take
a deep breath in.
And gently, exhale.
Let's take the attention to
all the sounds around us,
keeping the eyes closed.
The sounds of people walking
behind or talking, gentle
sounds.
Breathing in once again.
And gently, let's breathe out.
Allow the breath to go
in and out all by itself.
Without changing the
flow of the breathe,
just observe how the
breath is flowing.
It might be long or
short, shallow or deep.
Let there be a gentle
smile on the face,
even if it's artificial.
With a smile, breathe in.
And breathe out with a smile.
For a few minutes,
for a few seconds,
let's keep our body
as still as possible.
The feet are still.
The legs, knees, and thighs.
The spine is still and erect.
As the breath moves
in and out, there's
a rhythmic motion
happening all by itself.
The hands are still.
The neck is still.
And let the whole body
be as still as possible.
You might experience
a little discomfort.
Just for the next few
seconds, let's be with that.
For a little while,
nothing to do.
Nothing to know.
Just relax.
Let go of all your
efforts, and relax.
(CHANTING) Om.
Loka samasta sukhino bhuvantu.
Om shanti, shanti, shanti.
Gently, let's take
another deep breath in.
And slowly exhale.
And slowly and gradually
become aware of the body
and surroundings.
And whenever we feel
like it, at our own pace,
we may open our eyes.
Take your own time.
There's no hurry.
Good morning.
It just took a few minutes.
Yet, after all that talk,
just a few minutes of eyes
closed felt so relaxing.
And this is the power
of our own mind.
And as we can explore
deeper and get
to know more about all these
aspects of ourself, something
that is so-- seems
inconsequential,
can have great consequences.
Something that starts
off very simple,
just moving the
shoulders, can eventually
have an impact on the mind.
And this is the knowledge from
the Vedas, how all of this
is interconnected.
It's like when you catch one
leg of the chair and pull,
all the other legs
come together.
In that sense, all of this
knowledge, all the Vedas,
it has so much to offer us.
And we start from somewhere,
with some small technique
somewhere, and that
opens up something
that is useful not
just for ourself,
but not interaction with--
it helps in so many ways.
That's been my-- for
the last 20 years,
I have been teaching
these techniques,
talking to people across
the world, traveling.
And it's been so satisfying
to see all these techniques
having such an impact.
So I love doing this,
and this is what I do.
And I can go on and on and on,
because this is my passion.
But I can see that we are almost
close to just five minutes away
from the end.
It's been one hour that
we have been sitting here.
It doesn't feel like it.
So if you have any
questions, anything to ask
or anything to say,
please feel free to.
AUDIENCE: So I had a
question about the comment
that you made about doing
this while you're eating.
And I know maybe
it's just a joke,
but I read some
research on the subject,
and I found that
not eating actually
causes people stress, people
who are trying to lose weight.
DINESH KASHIKAR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And so it's
actually counterproductive,
because that stress causes
them to want to eat more.
DINESH KASHIKAR: More.
Right.
AUDIENCE: And so
that's a problem.
So I was wondering if
that's just a joke,
or if you have a few
words to say on--
DINESH KASHIKAR: On not eating.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DINESH KASHIKAR: So,
yeah, in that context,
obviously I wanted to
lighten up the atmosphere,
and it was not part of my talk.
But usually, when I
conduct a yoga session,
like some of these, it helps
to lighten up the atmosphere.
That changes the
state of the mind.
So yes, in that sense, it was
intended more as a bit levity
rather than
something so serious.
In Sanskrit, there is a saying
which says [SPEAKING SANSKRIT].
It means excess of
anything is not good.
So in that sense, I would
say moderation definitely
is the way to go, neither going
overboard nor going underboard.
Yeah, you're right.
AUDIENCE: I think
I read somewhere
that your breath pattern follows
the quote unquote "moon cycle."
And so that's why you
breathe in from one nostril,
and it switches to the
other, and it repeats.
And so when you
switch, artificially,
how to breathe, what's
the significance of that?
DINESH KASHIKAR: I'm sure
there are many studies that
are happening, but
I would say there
are a lot of aspects
of own physiology
that we are still exploding.
We really don't know
much about ourself,
and the envelope of knowledge
is increasing day by day.
One thing which is a
very interesting study
is how our breath
patterns keep changing,
like you just mentioned.
If you notice, sometimes
we feel one nostril
is more active than the other.
And this keeps flipping.
It keeps changing.
What I have experienced by
doing all these practice,
especially the nadi sodhana,
the alternate nostril breathing,
is it helps to calm the
mind in a certain way.
Of course, all this
is anecdotal evidence.
More and more people who do
this find it easier to meditate.
What happens during this thing?
I'm not a medical practitioner
nor a medical researcher,
so I really don't know about
it, nor is it appropriate
for me to comment about it.
But as a yoga teacher,
I've seen this technique
used very effectively
before a meditation.
It helps the mind to calm
down and to be more balanced.
So I would hazard a guess,
I would say that, you know,
breathing in different
patterns helps
to make an impact on
the state of the mind.
Usually some of the
questions that I get asked
is, after this, it's easy to
come and sit here and meditate
when you're giving instructions.
But how do I do it on my own?
Usually, when I sit on my own,
my mind goes here and there.
So one takeaway-- oh,
was that a question?
That's why, in this session,
one takeaway that I thought
we could put together is we
actually created an Android
app, where we have all
these instructions,
and you can have a meditation
timer, so to speak.
So it helps you to meditate
and track your meditation.
And that's what you
see up out there.
It says android:
sattva-meditation timer.
So this is called the
sattva meditation timer.
It helps to-- so there are
some instructions there,
and you can use the app and
do your meditation by yourself
with the instructions.
A good time to do it is before
breakfast, before lunch,
before dinner, when the
stomach is not full.
Usually if the stomach is
full and you close your eyes,
it's a very potent combination.
So it's a good idea to do this.
Even if you do it for
about a few minutes,
5 or 10 minutes
regularly, every day,
it can make a big difference.
Meditation, I would
say, is not a quick fix.
It's not that, OK, I want to
have higher efficiency today,
so let me meditate today.
There's no point digging the
well when the house is on fire.
But if you dig your
well and keep it ready,
then even if there
is a fire, you
have the means to put it out.
And that really is what
meditation is all about.
It's more a preventive
rather than a cure.
And, in fact, in
the "Yoga Sutras,"
one of the texts
on yoga, Patanjali
says that [SPEAKING SANSKRIT].
The whole purpose of
all these techniques
is to remove the misery
that has not yet come.
So in a sense, regular
practice of all these things
can have an impact on the mind
and can make a big difference
to the way we live our life.
So just summarizing,
once again, the four
Vedas-- the four ways of looking
at knowledge, whether it's
ideation, management,
creating harmony out of that,
or making it very practical
to day to day life.
And to do that, we have
the six Vedangas-- the way
to improve communication
through sound, words, grammar,
through the intonation, the
rhythm, through the timing
and through the context.
And then, the six
darshanas, or the ways
of looking at this knowledge.
Nyaya-- logic,
practical experience.
Yoga and Samkhya--
analysis versus synthesis.
And Mimamsa and Vedanta, or
getting into rituals, getting
caught up in one form
of thinking, or allowing
the freedom to happen.
So recognizing all these
aspects and developing
all these aspects.
Where you need to have
order, you need order.
And where you need to
think out of the box,
you need to think
out of the box.
So developing all
these aspects, which
is what all the
techniques do, which
is what all the meditation,
all these things
allow us all the abilities
of the mind to develop.
And that's why the
practical techniques.
So I enjoyed being
here with all of you.
I hope all of you also
enjoy being here with me.
And maybe it's
useful in some way.
I know one hour is too short
a time to really do justice
to such a vast topic.
And I hope we can meet
sometime, any time.
Do feel free to
follow up on this.
Mark is here in Google, and
he does some very interesting
things.
So there's that
go/SkyMeditation.
Oh, I should--
MARK BALL: Thank you, Kashi.
[APPLAUSE]